[Music]
hey Bill my name is Wendy and my
question is would the world be a better
place if everyone was an atheist or had
no beliefs in God or religion Wendy this
is a great question
practically I don't know people get a
lot of community out of religions they
get a lot of friendship they have
extended families as a result of
religion and my atheist friends and just
you know the old saying some of my best
friends or atheists I mean I do have a
large circle of atheist friends we're
all very supportive we have our own
community in a different way so I think
what we want is to transcend families
extended families and tribes to an
understanding that everybody in the
world is in this together that all of
our tribes are in them together people
from different religious traditions
we're all in this together and whether
or not there is one God that makes
decisions for you whether or not there's
one God that influences your life based
on what you've done in past lives
whether or not there is no God these are
all questions that are very important to
ponder individually but in the bigger
picture I'm not going to claim the world
would be better with or without
communities I think the communities and
interactions of tribes tribal style
nations and groups is very important to
the future of humankind so as you may
know I am NOT a believer I'm a
non-believer I spent a lot of time
trying to understand my place in the
cosmos and I've I've reached my own
conclusions but I'm the first to say
that ultimately we are all agnostic this
is to say you can't know whether or not
there is a giant entity running the show
or choosing to not run the show you
can't know so we all are best
I believe best served by just living
good lives trying to lead the world
better than we found it it's a great
question
[Music]